now one of the world's leading allergy
experts say they are not being
identified early enough because health
care workers untrained to spot the signs
well a sharp increase in sufferers over
the past 20 years means allergic disease
is the most common chronic disorder in
childhood skies Gemma Morris reports
eating isn't taken for granted when
you're a child with 12 severe food
allergies six of which a
life-threatening dairy and all forms of
saying clear to cheese and cream your
milk your ice cream all forms of nuts
all forms of tree nut seeds tomato Kiwi
peppers citrus dust cats dogs pollen
excruciating eczema has been one of the
most debilitating effects here at just a
few weeks old rashes thought to have
been triggered by dairy in Natalie's
breast milk he was bright red team's
Posse there was blood his skin didn't
look clear at any point at all you would
pick him up in the morning and it looked
like a murder being committed in his
Moses basket it was absolutely horrific
and it did matter how many times we went
to the doctors they would just say oh
it's just baby eczema or it's just colic
or it's just a bit of reflux so get over
it but deep down you know is mum there's
a lot more going on there can't be too
many four year olds who carry an
emergency medical kit take this feeling
a little early but considering half of
all children in the UK now have some
kind of allergy perhaps it's not too
surprising one of the world's leading
specialists is among those who say
health care provision hasn't been able
to keep pace with the scale of the
allergy epidemic looking at peanut
allergy alone this is doubled over the
last two decades so just under three
percent of children in the UK and North
America Australasia on our fected by
peanut allergy so this has been a rapid
rise they on are one in 30 that's one in
every classroom affected by peanut
allergy and I'm sure you can remember
back to your own school days where very
few children were affected in an entire
school the number of people being
hospitalized with severe allergic
reactions has gone up by 615
sent in the last 20 years it's little
wonder the charity allergy UK says it's
getting more calls from people looking
for help and advice there are pockets in
the country where the provision is so
virtually non-existent is probably the
best way I can put it we have a helpline
and parents that come through to our
helpline sometimes a desperate for help
for their children they just don't know
where to go nothing gets Callum down
though especially when he's eating his
mum's cooking and for parents trying to
get the right help for their child
natalie has this fight trust your
instincts believe in what you are saying
even if no one else is do your food
diary start from the morning all the way
through tonight what you feed them what
the nappies look like and please listen
to mom's mums know their children Gemma
Morris sky knees